well the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
oversees the entire u.s military it's a
big job a lot of weapons the fate of the
nation resting on his shoulders
in the case of the joe biden
administration and by the way the trump
administration same guy
the chairman of the joint chiefs is a
man called mark milley
at a hearing this week milly explained
that he is deeply concerned about
something not the threat from china
not the state of readiness among the
troops no no
he's concerned about white rage he
didn't explain what that is
but he said it's a huge problem white
rage watch
i do think it's important actually uh
for
those of us in uniform to be open-minded
and be widely read and the united states
military academy is a university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
and i i want to understand white rage
and i'm white and i want to understand
it
so what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to analyze it
it's important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians
they come from the american people so it
is important that the leaders
now and in the future do understand it
so let's be really clear white rage is
not a medical condition
it's not even a legitimate academic
theory it doesn't exist
white rage is a racial attack it's an
attack against people on the basis of
their skin color
so here you have the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
in a congressional hearing leveling
a race attack against american citizens
the guy is supposed to be protecting our
country that is disgraceful
it's disqualifying it's without
precedent when was the last time that
happened
and not only is it okay to complain
about it
it ought to be mandatory we shouldn't
have a chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
who attacks americans based on their
skin color it's disgusting
sean parnell served in afghanistan he's
a decorated combat veteran he's now
running for the united states senate
from pennsylvania he joins us tonight
sean panel thanks so much for coming on
so there is this
feeling even among republicans that if
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
comes out in a hearing and all of a
sudden starts attacking people because
of their skin color you're just supposed
to ignore it because he's a general and
you're not shut up
do you think we should ignore this yeah
no no if you were looking for a way to
destroy the united states military from
the inside out without firing a shot
talk about what he's talking about and
implement critical race theory it's a
disaster
it's dangerous it makes it harder to
accomplish the mission and ultimately i
think it will cost lives on the
battlefield i was blessed to lead
an infantry platoon on the border of
afghanistan and pakistan we were
probably the most diverse unit that you
could possibly imagine
northerners serving next to southerners
black next to white christians next to
atheists next to jews
rich next to poor young versus old and
yeah democrats next to republicans right
but we didn't focus on our many
differences there were no
hyphenated americans with us in
afghanistan
and what we realized our secret weapon
was wasn't the sexy guns and equipment
that we had
it was the love and brotherhood that we
had for one another
that allowed us to defeat the enemy at
every single turn
tucker critical race theory undermines
all of that it's a disaster when men and
women raise the right hand to serve this
country they do so because they believe
that america is an exceptional nation
worth defending
critical race theory undermines that
because it teaches america
it teaches people that america is
fundamentally bad
it's evil its systems need to be
reinvented because
at their core well they're racist that
tucker is a national security threat
and what truly bothers me is the
chairman of joint chiefs of staff
should be focused on an exit strategy in
afghanistan
but afghanistan for 20 years over half
of my life
and instead he's reading lenin marks
studying critical race theory
how about we how about we get an exit
strategy in afghanistan how about we
focus on bringing our men and women home
and taking care of them
when they come home because tucker if
the chairman of the
chiefs does not recognize the threat
the caustic nature of critical race and
the threat that it poses to our military
then i think that he should consider
resigning
like i couldn't agree with you more and
i love your point
that our military is successful because
it's cohesive
people who are in a lot of ways
different are united
in a mission as americans and when you
fray those bonds when you force people
to focus on what divides them
you're less effective fighting force i
mean since you put it that way just it
makes a lot of sense why wouldn't he
know that
yeah critical race theory is a threat
because it divides people into little
groups
and it undermines trust in the
battlefield and if if there's no trust
on the battlefield when the bullets
start
cracking by your head i mean there's
hesitation that hesitation leads to
death
on the battlefield right soldiers need
to be able to come together look past
their many differences in fact that's
part of the training
so critical race theory needs to go away
in fact members of congress on both
sides of the aisle need to act we should
ban critical race theory
from the military yesterday amen
really quick looking from the outside in
the u.s military seems like
by far the least racist institution in
american life
and has been for many decades is that
yeah right
that's the way it seems in a great way
it's absolutely true we've got
we have been a colorblind culture in the
united states military
for almost 200 years we've gotten a lot
of things right
keep your politi your politics and your
social experiments
out of our military and let us focus on
what we were always intended to do
protecting the united states of america
and winning wars yeah
sean parnell so nicely put thanks for
coming on tonight
good luck in your race thanks sir you
got it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else